detectives announcing that they have
charged a 31 year old man Jamie Barrow
with three murder three counts of murder
what is significant about this
announcement is they give the address of
the man that they've charged Jamie
Barrow a Fair Isle close Clifton that is
where I'm standing this is a quiet
residential cul-de-sac in Nottingham at
the flat the first floor flat just
behind me here is where this terrible
fire took hold in the early hours of
Sunday morning and now police announcing
that the man that they've had in custody
since Sunday evening the man that
they've charged this evening is indeed a
neighbor of the victims now the victims
of this fire Fatima haidara she was 28
years old and her two young children
Fatima drama who was three and Neymar
drama who was just one neighbors here
described horrendous scenes in the early
hours of Sunday morning as first of all
the children were brought out by
firefighters were given CPR out here on
the street before being taken to
hospital where very sadly they were
pronounced dead soon after arriving at
hospital their mother Fatima was then
put on life support there were hopes
from her family that she might pull
through but on Tuesday she too was
pronounced dead and I've got some words
following the charge of this 31 year old
man Jamie Barrow from Rob Griffin the
assistant chief Constable of
Nottinghamshire police he says our
thoughts remain with the family at this
incredibly painful time as well as the
communities that have been affected by
this most tragic of incidents the grief
this family has been put through is
incomprehensible large teams of
detectives have been working Relentless
relentlessly alongside specialist search
units and forensic experts to understand
the full circumstances behind this
deliberate fire following those
inquiries we've charged a Suspect with
three counts of murder the family are
aware of this development and I would
like to sincerely thank them for their
patience and understanding as we do
everything we can to gain justice so the
breaking news is that a 31 year old man
has been charged with three counts of
murder he's due to appear at magistrates
court tomorrow morning